at that time this was the the the most
tough period in my life yeah but
actually from the other side this was my
most beautiful part of the life because
I was never so satisfied with myself
because I I knew I'm close to my my my
lord
yeah and actually at that time I was
alone nobody was with me not my friends
that's my family my mother I was walking
on the street you know I was hungry no
money to be honest I sleep on the road
you know she kicked you out she kick now
you were kicked out just driven out of
your own just like that so wait your
parents technically they're like are
they because from the former Yugoslavia
you have many people were communist so
they left release right so were they
have that mindset Same Same Same Same so
they're like atheist yes like it is yeah
okay so they kicked you out they kick me
out yeah and you know but I was
satisfied I was everyday I was praying
and continuing my way because I knew
this is the the right way and one day
Allah will change all this because this
is what he what he told us and now that
time I was just reading just reading you
know in Quran and the our authentic
books and we had like one one meeting
family meeting a big family meeting and
I was such I was surprised when they
invited me because I was now kicked out
but now they called you somehow because
the family is getting together yes so
you got an invite yes okay and maybe the
mother is more soft right she's but
she's made missing you she have tell you
she wants to see you maybe did she told
them because you know yeah I wanted my
son be here
yes we don't like him but but he should
be with us and and they don't it's not
that they don't like you because you're
a troublemaker
you stop being a trouble miss and you
just start praying that you just started
can you know being a Muslim I was
sitting one time with them and they just
you know they may have a bit they just
peek about other people on the bed way
yeah I was not talking with them yeah
just take maybe two hours after two
hours the chairman of our family my
uncle
just jump stand up and said this guy's
crazy he don't want even speak bad about
people because in in you know many
people don't know this aspect it's
actually a major sin and many you know
houses would be saved marriages
relationships if people don't gossip
behind each other's backs and so you
weren't jumping in because usually
people have dinner helping out and
instead of talking about some productive
they're talking about he said she said I
was talking about people behind people's
back and you didn't have no you didn't
wanna have no part of that you got in
trouble for that huh and they kick them
out
oh yeah yeah so anyway I at that time I
came they kicked me just out now let me
ask you this hold on let me be you know
[Music]
objective here
no actually I'm gonna play play on the
other side and think like hold on
because sometimes when people do accept
Islam they get a little bit some people
are over enthusiastic rigid and they
come at people a little bit rough
was there some of that that maybe you
like scared them off a little bit or
maybe yes when you look back were you a
little bit too tough I was a little bit
too tough yeah maybe because at that
time I saw what's Islam and I just
wanted everybody for my family my
friends start parks noisy people want
people to develop ideas your spiritual
time yes yeah I'm to be honest this was
my my situation I was like that a little
bit tough you know at that time I should
be maybe more soft but you know I was
alone yes why I thought this is the
right way yeah I didn't shout on them I
didn't said bad words just I was you
know if I sit with them if they started
to she said he said I just stopped I
didn't yeah maybe I don't know sometimes
yeah but it's happened like that are in
people's in experiences and what I
usually the beginning phases are like
that so what happens now so now they
invite you back to the house and what
happens